The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: [INAUDIBLE]
of today's lecture
is coherent states of
the harmonic oscillator.
So let me begin by telling
you about some things
we've learned in the last
lecture, and here they are.
We learned how to calculate the
so-called Heisenberg operators.
Remember, if you have
a Schrodinger operator,
you subject it to
this transformation
with a unitary operator.
That creates time evolution
and that gives you
the Heisenberg operator.
We learned things about
Heisenberg expectation values.
If the Hamiltonian is
time independent, h, time
independent, the
formula is quite simple
and gives you the Heisenberg
operator at the later time.
So we did this.
We found, in fact,
Heisenberg operators
satisfy equations of motion.
And we calculated the
Heisenberg operators
for the harmonic oscillator.
That was our main
achievement last time,
a formula for the time
development of the x
and p operators in the
Heisenberg picture.
And that really contains all
the information of the dynamics,
as you will see today, when
we will be using this stuff.
Now, I suggested that you
read-- and you may do it later.
There's no need
that you've done it
for today-- the
information on the time
development of the creation
and annihilation operators.
You see, the a and a dagger are
different inverses of x and p,
are linear combinations.
So the a and the
a dagger operators
also can be further
Schrodinger operators
that have no time dependence.
And suddenly, if you go
to the Heisenberg picture,
the creation and
annihilation operators
become time dependent operators.
So that's in the notes.
You can read about it.
So we define the time
dependent operator, a hat,
to be the Heisenberg
version of a hat.
And you're supposed
to do a calculation
and try it or read it, and
the answer is very nice,
simply a phase dependence.
The a is a at time equals
0, the Schrodinger 1 times
e to the minus i omega t.
Then a dagger is just
what you would expect,
the dagger of this, which the
face has an opposite sign and a
becomes a dagger.
Finally, if you
substitute this a and a
daggers in this formula.
For example, you
could say x Heisenberg
is a Heisenberg plus
a dagger Heisenberg.
And you substitute those
Heisenberg values there,
you will obtain this.
Same for the momentum.
If you put Heisenberg,
Heisenberg, Heisenberg,
remember, if you have an
equality of Schrodinger
operators, it also
holds when you
put Heisenberg in
every operator.
And therefore, if you
put the Heisenberg a, a,
and use those values, you
will recover this equation.
So in a sense, these equations
are equivalent to these ones.
And that's basically
our situation.
This is what we've
learned so far,
and our goal today is to
apply this to understand
coherent states of the
harmonic oscillator.
Now, why do we
want to understand
coherent states of the
harmonic oscillator?
You want to understand coherent
states because the energy
eigenstates are
extraordinarily quantum.
The energy eigenstates of
the harmonic oscillator
don't look at all-- and
you've seen the expectation
value of the position.
It's time independent.
It just doesn't change.
Expectation value of any
operator in a stationary state
is a constant.
It just doesn't change.
So you have any eigenstate,
any energy eigenstate
of the harmonic
oscillator, you ask,
what is the position
of this particle doing?
Nothing.
What is the momentum
of this particle doing?
Nothing.
So nevertheless, of course,
it's an interesting state,
but we want to construct
quantum mechanical states that
behave a little like the
classical states we're
accustomed to.
And that's what
coherent states do.
We'll have an application
of coherent states
to light, photons,
coherent photons.
What are they?
We'll see it later this week.
So that's the reason we want
to understand coherent states,
because we want some
states that in some ways
behave classically, or
close to classically.
So they have many
applications, these states,
and you will see some
of them in this lecture.
I'm going to try to keep this
blackboard there, untouched,
so that we can refer
to these equations.
So our first step is considering
translation operators.
So let's consider the
unitary translation operator.
So translation operators.
So this translation operator
that I will write as T sub x0
will be defined to be
the exponential of e
to the minus i p
hat x0 over h bar.
You have seen such
operators before.
We've seen a lot of
them in the homework.
So first of all,
why is it unitary?
well, it's unitary because x0
is supposed to be a real number.
p is Hermitian.
Therefore, this with
the i is anti-Hermitian,
and an exponential of
anti-Hermitian operator
is unitary.
Now, it has, actually,
a very simple property.
The multiplication of two
of those operators is what?
Well, you have an exponential,
e to the minus ipx0,
and an exponential followed,
e to the minus ipy0.
Now, if you're well
trained in 805,
you should get a little
nervous for a second
because you don't know,
can I treat it easily?
And then you relax and say,
yes, these two operators,
whatsoever the numbers here,
this with another one with a y0
would commute.
Therefore, they can be put
together in the exponential,
and this is T of x0 plus y0.
No combo Baker-Hausdorff
needed here.
It's just straightforward.
So what is Tx0 dagger?
T x0 dagger, if you
take the dagger,
you change this i for
a minus i, so it's
exactly the same as
changing the sign of x0.
So this is T of minus x0.
And by this identity, T
of minus x0 with a T of x0
would be T of 0, which
is the unit operator.
So T of minus x0 is
the inverse of T of x0,
confirming that the
operator is unitary.
The inverse is the dagger.
So I used here that
this is the inverse
because T minus x0 times T
x0 is T of 0 is equal to 1.
So I could mention here, T of 0
is equal to the unit operator.
So these are our
translation operators,
but you don't get
the intuition of what
they do unless you
compute a little more.
And a little more than you
should compute is this.
What is T x0 dagger x T x0?
And what is T x0 dagger p T x0?
Now, why do we ask for
these particular things?
Why don't I ask, what is
x hat multiplied by T x0?
Why do I ask this?
It is because an operator
acting on an operator
always does this.
If you say an operator is
acting on another operator,
the first operator
that is acting,
you put it here
with its inverse.
It happens to be unitary,
so you put the dagger,
and you put the operator here.
And this is the
right thing to do.
It has a simple answer and
a simple interpretation,
as we'll see now.
So what is T, this
commutator, supposed to be?
Well, you can probably
imagine what this is.
You've calculated
it in homework,
so I will not do it again.
This is x plus x0.
So you get the operator, x,
plus x0 times the unit operator.
That was done before.
And here, you get just p.
Why?
Because p hat is
the only operator
that exists in this translation
thing, so p commutes with p.
So these two operators commute
and the T tagger hits the T,
and it's equal to 1, so
that's a simple thing.
So why is this reasonable?
It's because of the
following situation.
If you have a state, psi,
you can ask, for example,
what is the expectation
value of x in the state psi?
And if this state
represents a particle that
is sitting somewhere here,
roughly, the expectation value
of x is basically
that vector that
tells you where the particle is.
So you could ask, then,
what is the expectation
value of x in the
state T x0 psi?
So you want to know,
what does T x0 really do?
Here, it seems to say
something, takes the operator
and displaces it, but
that seems abstract.
If you ask this question,
this seems more physical.
You had a state, you act with
an operator, it's another state.
How does it look?
Well, this expectation value
would be the expectation value
of x on T x0 psi,
and the [? brau ?]
would be psi T x0 dagger.
So actually, that
expectation value
builds precisely
this combination,
and that's why it's meaningful.
And since you know what this
is, this is psi x plus x0 psi.
This is equal to the
expectation value
of x in the original
state plus x0 times 1.
So the expectation value of x
in the new state, the x0 psi,
is the expectation value of
x in the old state plus x0.
So indeed, if this is x, you
could do this for vectors,
and here is x0.
Well, the expectation value of
x in the new state, the T x0
operator, took the state and
moved it by a displacement x0
so that the new expectation
value is the old one plus x0.
So that's physically why
these things are relevant.
A couple of other things
you've shown in the homework,
and you could retry doing them,
is that T x0 on the x state,
by this intuition, should
be the x plus x0 state.
It moves the state to the right.
And if psi has a wave
function, psi of x, T x0 of psi
has a wave function,
psi of x minus x0,
since you know that
psi of x minus x0
is the wave function
translated by x0 to the right.
The sign is always
the opposite one.
When you write
psi of x minus x0,
the function has been
moved to the right x0.
So this is our whole
discussion and reminder
of what the translation
operators are.
So we've got our
translation operator.
Let's see how we can use it.
And we'll use it to define
the coherent states.
So here comes the definition
of what the coherent state is.
It's a beginning definition,
or a working definition,
until we understand it enough
that we can generalize it.
By the time we
finish the lecture,
this definition will be
generalized in a very nice way,
in a very elegant way.
So coherent states.
So here it goes.
I'm going to take the
vacuum state of the harmonic
oscillator, the ground state
of the harmonic oscillator,
and simply displace it with
a translation operator by x0.
So this is going to be e to the
minus i p hat x0 over h bar 0.
And I want a name
for this state,
and that's the worst part of it.
There's no great name for it.
I don't know if any
notation is very good.
If it's very good,
it's cumbersome,
so I'll write it like this.
A little misleading.
I'll put a tilde over the state.
You could say it's
a tilde over the x,
but it really,
morally speaking, is
a tilde over the whole state.
It means that this
thing, you should
read there's an x0 here used for
the translation operator that
appears here.
So that's the state, x tilde 0.
Intuitively, you
know what it is.
You have the harmonic
oscillator potential.
Here is x.
The ground state is some
wave function like that.
This state has been
moved to position x0,
and presumably some sort
of wave function like that,
because this translates
the wave function.
So the ground state moves
it up there to the right.
That's what it is.
That's a coherent state.
And there's no time
dependence here so far,
so this is the state at
some instant of time.
The coherent state, maybe
call it at time equals zero.
Let's leave time frozen
for a little while
until we understand
what this state does.
Then we'll put the time back.
So a few remarks on this.
x0 x0 is how much?
Now, don't think these
are position eigenstates.
That's a possible mistake.
That's not a
position eigenstate.
This is a coherent state.
If these would be
position eigenstate,
you say delta of
this minus that,
but it's nothing
to do with that.
Can you tell without
doing any computation what
is this number?
How much should be?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: 1.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: It should be 1.
Why?
Because it's a unitary
operator acting on this thing,
so it preserve length.
So this should be equal
to 0 0, should be 1.
Very good.
No need to do the computation.
It's just 1.
Psi associated to this state is
the ground state wave function
at x minus x0.
Where this refers to the wave
function, x0 is psi 0 of x.
So this is what I
was saying here.
The wave function
has been translated
to x0, the remark over there.
So these are our
coherent states and we
want to understand the first
few basic things about them
so we can do the following
simple computations.
So if I have to
do the following,
if I have to compute
the expectation
value of any operator,
A, on a coherent state,
I use the fact that I want
to go back to the vacuum,
so I put T x0 dagger A T x0 0.
Because that way, I trace back
to what the vacuum is doing.
It's much easier to do that than
to try to calculate something
from scratch.
So for example, we have
here that x0 x x0, well, you
would replace it by T x T,
T dagger x T, which you know
is x hat plus x0.
We calculated it a few
seconds ago, top blackboard.
And therefore, you got
what is the expectation
value of x on the ground state?
x0, very good.
And therefore, we just got x0,
which is what you would expect.
The expectation value of x
on the coherent state is x0.
You're there.
You've been displaced.
How about the
momentum, x0 p hat x0?
Well, p acted by the translation
operator is unchanged.
Therefore, we got 0 p 0, and
again that 0, so this state
still has no momentum.
It represents a T equals 0,
a state that is over here.
And just by looking at it,
it's just sitting there,
has no momentum whatsoever.
Another question
that is interesting,
what is the expectation
value of the Hamiltonian
on the coherent state?
Well, this should be, now
you imagine in your head,
T dagger H T. Now, H
is p squared over 2m,
and that p squared
over 2m gets unchanged.
p squared over 2m is not changed
because T dagger and T does
nothing to it, T dagger
from the left, T.
Nevertheless.
the Hamiltonian has a 1/2
m omega squared x hat,
and x hat is changed by
becoming x hat plus x0.
Well, we don't want to
compute too hard, do
too much effort here.
So first, we realize that
here's the p squared over 2m
and here's the m omega squared
x hat squared, so that's
the whole Hamiltonian.
So we got 0 H 0 plus the
extra terms that come here.
But what terms come here?
There's a product of an x0
and an x between 0 and 0.
x0 is a number, so you have an
x between 0 and 0, and that's 0.
So the cross product here won't
contribute to the expectation
value, so the last term
that is there is 1/2 m
is a number omega
squared, x0 squared.
And what is the
expectation value
of the Hamiltonian
on the vacuum?
It's h omega over 2 plus 1/2
m omega squared, x0 squared.
And you start seeing
classical behavior.
The expectation value of
the energy at this point
is a little quantum
thing plus the whole cost
of stretching something
all the way to x0.
1/2 of k squared, k for
the oscillator, x0 squared.
So the energy of this thing is
quite reasonably approximated,
if x0 is large enough,
by the second term,
and this is the cost
of energy of having
a particle of the potential.
So it's behaving in
a reasonable way.
You can do a couple more
little exercises that I'll
put here as things
for you to check.
Exercise.
x0 tilde x squared x0 tilde.
Just calculate.
It's just useful to have.
x0 squared plus h
bar over 2m omega.
And x0 tilde p squared x0
tilde is mh omega over 2.
And finally, x0 tilde xp plus
px x0 tilde is equal to 0.
Any questions?
These are exercises
for you to practice
a little these
expectation values.
Questions on what
we've done so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You said
these coherent states is
most significant only
in the ground state,
or is it also important to
use them for [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Well, we've
defined the coherent state
by taking the ground
state and moving it,
and these are
particularly interesting.
You could try to figure out what
would happen if you would take
an excited state
and you move it.
Things are a little
more complicated.
PROFESSOR: And in a
sense, they can all
be understood in terms of what
we do to the ground state.
So we will not focus
on them too much.
In a sense, you will
see when we generalize
this how what we're doing
is very special, in at least
one simple way.
So we'll always focus on
translating the grounds.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Where does the
term [INAUDIBLE] arise
and why does it
persevere [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, here is the
thing of the coherent state.
Is this an energy
eigenstate at this moment?
What do you think?
Is this an energy eigenstate--
this state over here?
No, it won't be an
energy eigenstate.
There's something
funny about it.
Energy eigenstates are
always diffuse things.
They never look like that.
So this is not an
energy eigenstate,
and you've done things with
non-energy eigenstates.
They change shape.
As they evolve,
they change shape.
What we will see very
soon is that this state,
if we let it go, it will
start moving back and forth
without changing shape.
It's going to do
an amazing thing.
Energy eigenstates-- you're
super-close to energy
eigenstates.
You get something that changes
in time and the shape changes,
and you've even done
problems like that.
But this state is so
exceptional that even
as we let it go in time,
it's going to change,
but the shape is not
going to spread out.
Do you remember when
you considered a pulse
in a free particle, how it
disappears and stretches away?
Well, in the
harmonic oscillator,
this has been so well prepared
that this thing, as time goes
by, will just move and
oscillate like a particle.
And it does so coherently.
It doesn't change shape.
When we talk about
light, coherent light
is what you get from lasers.
And so if you want
understand lasers,
you have to understand
coherent states.
OK, so this brings us
there to time evolution.
So let's do time evolution.
So what will happen?
We'll have a state x0
goes to x0 comma t.
So that's the notation.
That's what we'll mean by
the state at a later time.
And how are we going
to explore this?
Well, we're all set with our
Heisenberg operator, there.
We'll take expectation
values of things
to figure out how things look.
So what do we have here?
We'll ask for X0 t, and we'll
put the Schrodinger operator
in between here--
X0 t, and this is
what we'll call the
expectation value of A
as time goes by
in the X0 0 state.
This is what we call this.
But then, we have
the time evolution.
So this is equal to the original
state, Heisenberg operator
of A-- original state.
And if you wish, you could
then put the t operator--
as we have in the top
blackboard to the right--
and reduce it even more.
But we've computed a lot of
this coherent state expectation
value, so let's
leave it like that.
So you could, if
you wish, say this
is equal to 0-- T
X0 dagger A T X0 0.
So you can ultimately reduce
the expectation values
of things on the vacuum.
So OK, we're all set.
Let's try to do one.
And the reason this
is a nice calculation
is that the time
evolution of this state
is a little complicated.
We'll figure it out
later, but it's easier
to work with the
time evolved state.
So here it goes-- what
is the expectation
value of X as a function
of time on the X0 state?
Well, it says here
take the X0 state,
and take the
Heisenberg value of X.
So we have it up there-- X
hat cosine omega t plus b hat
over M omega sine omega t X0.
Forget about time evolution
of the coherent states.
We evolved the operator.
On the other hand, we have
that the expectation value of p
is 0 in the coherent state,
and the expectation value of X
is X0.
So end of story-- calculation
over-- X0 cosine of omega t.
That's expectation
value in time.
This thing is
oscillating classically.
That's nice as can be.
So classical behavior
again, of a quantum state.
How about expectation
value of p X0 of t?
If it's oscillating,
it better be moving,
and it better have
some momentum.
So let's put the
momentum operator here,
the Heisenberg one.
So we'll have p hat cosine
omega t minus m omega x
hat sine omega t X0 tilde.
And this is 0, but
X has X0 there,
so minus m omega X0
sine of omega t, which
is equal to m d dt of the
expectation value of X.
Here it is-- expectation
value of X. m d dt of that
is minus m omega
X0 sine omega t.
That's what it should be.
And this thing is really
oscillating classically--
not only the exposition, but
the momentum is doing that.
Now, the other thing
that we can compute--
and we want to compute--
is the key thing.
You have this state.
We said it's coherent evolution.
So the ground
state is this state
that is a minimum
uncertainty packet.
It has a delta X uncertainty
mix and a delta p.
Their product saturates the
uncertainty in equality.
And when we move the state
X0, well, the delta X
will be the same.
The delta p will be the
same, and it's that.
But now as it starts
to move, we want
to see if the shape
is kept the same.
Maybe it fattens up,
and shrinks down,
and does things in the middle.
So the issue of
coherency of this state
is the issue whether the
uncertainties remain the same.
If the uncertainties
remain the same,
and they are saturated--
the product is saturating
the inequality, you know that
the shape has to be Gaussian,
and it must be the same
shape that is running around.
So what we need to compute
is the uncertainty in X,
for example.
So how do delta X of t
and delta p of p behave?
That's our question.
And let's see how they do.
Well, we have this
computation-- actually,
if you don't have the
Heisenberg picture,
it's kind of a nightmare.
With the Heisenberg
picture, it's a lot easier.
Delta x squared of t
would be the expectation
value of X0 t of
X squared, X0 t,
minus the expectation value
of X0 t X, X0 t squared.
I wrote what the definition
of the uncertainty squared is.
It's the expectation value
of the operator squared,
minus the square
of the expectation
value of the operator.
And of course, everything
is going to turn Heisenberg
immediately, so this thing--
maybe I can go one more
line here-- would be X0 X
Heisenberg squared of t,
X0 minus-- this is simple--
this we've calculated.
it's that expectation
value at the top
is the expectation
value of X in time.
It's that.
So this is minus X0 squared
cosine squared of omega t.
So what do we have to do?
We have to focus on this term.
So this term is equal to X0.
And you have X
Heisenberg squared,
so let's do it-- X
squared cosine squared
omega t plus p
hat squared over m
squared w squared sine
squared omega t plus 1
over mw cosine omega t sine
omega t X p plus pX X0 tilde.
That shows that term, and
I just squared that thing,
but that I suggested
a few exercises here.
This is 0.
In fact, it's 0 in the ground
state as well, so this is 0.
X squared gives you
the top equation--
X0 squared plus h bar
over 2 m omega cosine
squared omega t-- plus p squared
over m squared w squared,
so p squared is
m h omega over 2.
And then you have
m squared omega
squared sine squared omega t.
And that's this whole term.
And the thing that
we're supposed to do
is subtract this here.
You see that the X0 squared
cosine squared of omega t
cancels here.
So what do we get?
h bar over 2 mw cosine
squared omega t.
But this thing is also h bar
over 2 mw sine squared omega t.
So this whole
thing, all the times
have disappeared--
delta X squared--
the time dependence here
has disappeared with that,
and the cosine squared with
sine squared have combined,
and you get h bar
over 2 m omega, which
was-- this is, I'm sorry, of t.
We work very hard
to put the t there.
We should leave it.
The uncertainty as a function
of time has not changed.
It is the original uncertainty
of the ground state.
So this is moving in a nice way.
You're supposed to compute now
as well the uncertainty in p.
I leave that as an
exercise-- delta
p squared of t equal
m h bar omega over 2.
So this is an exercise.
Practice with coherent states.
It's worth doing it, I think.
Actually there's going to
be a problem in the homework
set, in which you're going to
ask to do most of these things,
including things I'm doing
here on the blackboard.
So you will practice this.
So between these two, delta
p, delta X-- delta X of t,
delta p of t is, in fact,
equal to h bar over 2.
And this is a minimum
uncertainty thing.
And it behaves quite nicely.
All right, so the name
coherent now should make sense.
You've produced a
quantum state that
has about the energy of a state
that you're familiar with,
and it moves classically,
and it doesn't change shape
as it moves, so
it moves coherent.
So our next task,
therefore, will
be to understand this
in the energy basis.
Because in the energy basis,
it looks like a miracle.
You've suddenly
managed to produce
a set of states of
different energies,
created the superposition,
and suddenly, it
moves in a nice way.
Why does that happen?
So we need to understand
the energy basis.
And as we do that,
we'll understand
how to generalize the
coherent states completely.
So let's go on with
that, and let's
explore this in
the energy basis.
So what do we have?
We have the coherent state--
no need to put the time yet--
is e to the exponential of
minus i p hat X0 over h bar.
There is, as you've
seen already,
at length scale in the harmonic
oscillator-- famous length
scale, and we'll have
an abbreviation for it.
It's the length scale d0
squared h bar over m omega.
You can use the parameters of
the harmonic oscillator-- h bar
and m and omega-- to
produce a length scale.
And that length scale is d0.
It's essentially the uncertainty
in the position in the ground
state, up to the
square root of 2.
It's the way-- you want to
construct a length-- there
it is-- the only way you
can construct a length.
So I'm going to
use that notation.
So let me put what the p is into
that formula, and simplify it.
So this is on the vacuum-- I'm
sorry, I stopped half the way.
So this is the exponential of X0
over square root of 2d a dagger
minus a on the vacuum.
Plug in the p, get
the h bars, and you
will see that d
enters in that way.
It's the way it has to enter,
because this exponential should
have no units, and therefore
X0 over d0 has no units,
and the a's and the a
daggers have no units.
So it couldn't be any
way different like that.
The i also shouldn't be
there, because this operator--
the i was there to make
this anti-Hermitian.
But this, with this real,
is already anti-Hermitian.
You see, you take the dagger.
It becomes minus itself.
So this is anti-Hermitian.
No need for an i-- in
fact, an i would be wrong,
so there's no i.
And that's this.
Now, we want to figure out how
this looks in the energy basis,
so what are we going to do?
We're going to have
to do something
with that exponential.
We're going to
have to reorder it.
This is a job for
Baker-Campbell-Hausdorff.
Which one?
Well, this one-- e to the X
plus Y is equal to e to X,
e to the Y, e to
the minus 1/2-- I
don't know this by heart--
XY, and it stops there.
If and only if X commutator
with Y commutes with X,
and commutes with Y.
There was a problem
in the test that there
was an operator with
Xp plus pX acting on X,
and after you commuted,
you get X again,
and you have to keep
including terms.
So this stops here if XY
commutes with X and Y.
And why do I want this?
Because I actually want
to split the creation
and the manipulation operators.
I want them in
separate exponentials.
We have that energy eigenstates
are creation operators
on the vacuum, but here I have
creation minus destruction.
So if I expand the
exponential, I'm
going to get lots of
creation and destruction,
and I'm going to spend
hours trying to sort it out.
If you did expand it, I bet
you won't see it through
so easily-- probably
will take you forever,
and it might not work out.
So expanding an
exponential is something
that we should be
reluctant to do.
On the other hand,
this is a nice option,
because then you
think of this as e
to the X0 over square root
of 2d0 a dagger minus X0
over square root of 2d0 a.
And I chose this analogy X
with this, and Y with this.
It's like Y is this thing
minus that, and X is that.
You could have done it
the other way around,
but then you would run
into trouble again.
Why?
Because I want a Y factor
that has the manipulators
to be to the right of the X
factor that has the creation.
Why?
Because if I have annihilators
closer to the vacuum,
that's good.
Annihilators closer to the
vacuum is what you really want,
because if you have creators
close to the vacuum,
they create state, but then
you have the manipulators,
and you have to start
working them out.
On the other hand,
if the annihilators
are close to the vacuum,
they just kill the vacuum
and you can forget them.
So it's very important that
you identify X with this,
and Y with this whole thing.
So that this is e to the X0 over
square root of 2D0 a dagger, e
to the minus X0 over
square root of 2d0 a.
And now you're supposed to do
the commutator of these two
things.
And the commutator
is the commutator
of an a dagger with
an a, and that is 1.
So this commutator is
a number-- crucial,
because if it wasn't
a number, if it
would be an a or an a
dagger, it would not
commute with a, X, and Y, and
you have to include more terms.
So the fact that this
commutator is a number
allows you to use this formula.
So now we'll put this
factor here, minus 1/2.
Then you have X
with Y, and that's
X0 minus X0 over square
root of 2d squared,
minus-- and this factor
squared-- an a dagger
with a, which is minus 1.
So that's that whole operator.
So let's write it.
The coherent state,
therefore, X0 tilde,
is equal to e to the X0 over
square root of 2d0 a hat
dagger, e to the minus X0
over square root of 2d0 a,
and this factor that seems
to be e to the minus 1/4 X0
squared over d0 squared.
And here is this nice vacuum.
Yes, factor is right.
So what is this?
Well, this is a number, so
I can pull it to the left.
And here is the exponential
of the annihilator operator.
Now expand the exponential.
It's 1.
That survives, but the first
term has an a-- kills it.
The second term has an
a squared-- kills it.
Everything kills it.
This thing acting on
the vacuum is just 1.
That's why this is simple.
So what have we got?
In the state X0 tilde is e
to the minus 1/4 X0 squared
over d0 squared times e to
the X0 over square root of 2d0
a dagger on the vacuum.
Well this is nice-- not
quite energy eigenstates,
but we're almost there.
What is this?
e to the minus 1/4, X0
squared over d0 squared.
And now expand.
This is the sum from n
equals 1 to infinity,
1 over n factorial.
X0 over square root
of 2d0 to the n,
a hat dagger to the
n on the vacuum.
And what was the nth
energy eigenstate?
You probably remember.
The nth energy
eigenstate is a dagger
to the n on the vacuum over
square root of n factorial.
So we've got a little
more than the square root
of 2 n factorial.
So maybe I'll do it here.
We get e to the minus 1/4
X0 squared over d0 squared,
sum from n equals
1 to infinity, 1
over square root of n factorial,
X0 over the square root of 2 d0
to the n times the
nth energy eigenstate.
It's a little messy,
but not so bad.
I think actually I
won't need that anymore.
Well no, I may.
I will.
So let's write it maybe again.
Well, it's OK.
Let's write it as
follows-- Cn n.
OK, so I got some cn's and n's.
So this is a very
precise superposition
of energy eigenstates,
very delicate superposition
of energy eigenstates.
Let me write it in the
following way-- cn squared.
Why would I care
about cn squared?
cn squared is the probability
to find the coherent state
in the nth energy eigenstate.
The amplitude to have it in the
nth energy eigenstate is cn.
So that probability to find it
in the nth energy eigenstate
is cn squared, is the
probability 4x tilde 0
2b in the nth energy eigenstate.
That is what?
Exponential of minus 1/2
x0 squared over d0 squared.
And I have to square that.
So I have 1 over n factorial.
I have to square that
coefficient there.
So it's x0 squared over
2d0 squared-- that's
nice, it's the same
one here-- to the n.
So it's easier to
think of this if you
invent a new letter, lambda, to
be x0 squared over 2d0 squared.
Then, cn squared is equal to
e to the minus lambda lambda
to the n over n factorial.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that
something that we
should expect to be true
for any time of [INAUDIBLE],
or is that something
that we [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, let
me say it this way.
In a second, it
will become clear
that this was almost necessary.
I actually don't know very
deeply why this is true.
And I'm always a little puzzled
and uncomfortable at this point
in 805.
So what is really
strange about this
is that this is the so-called
Poisson distribution.
So there's something about
this energy eigenstate
that their Poisson distributed
in a coherent state.
So these are probabilities,
as I claimed, to find an n.
And indeed, let's check the
sum of the cn squareds from n
equals 1 to infinity.
Let's see what it is.
And you will see, you
cannot tinker with this.
This is e to the minus
lambda the sum from n
equals 1 to infinity lambda
to the n over n factorial.
And that sum-- it's
not from n equals 1.
It's 0 to infinity, I'm sorry.
Did I write once anywhere?
Yeah, it should be 0.
OK, this is 0.
There is the ground state, so
from n equals 0 to infinity.
And this is e to
the minus lambda e
to the lambda, which is 1.
So yes, this is
Poisson distributed.
It's some sort of
distribution like that.
So if you have the n's, the
cn's, Poisson distributions
have to do with if you have
a radioactive material.
It has a lifetime.
And you say, how many
events should I--
the lifetime is five years.
How many events should you
expect to happen in a week?
These are Poisson distributed.
So it's a Poisson distribution.
It's a very nice thing.
So let me just make one
more remark about it.
And it's quite something.
So one question
that you could ask
is, what is the most probable n?
That's a good question.
You have a coherent state.
So it's going to have
the superposition
of the vacuum, the first.
What is the most probable n,
so the expectation value of n?
Now, I'm thinking of
it probabilistically.
So I'm thinking this is a
probability distribution.
Then, I will show it for
you that this is really
computing what you want.
But probabilistically, what
is the expectation value of n?
You should sum n times the
probability that you get n.
So this is sum over ne to
the minus lambda lambda
to the n over n factorial.
So you got an n there.
And the way you get an n there--
well, the e to the minus lambda
goes out.
And the n can be reproduced
by doing lambda d d
lambda on the sum.
Because lambda d d lambda on
this sum brings down this n,
puts back the lambda so it
gives you the thing you had,
and that's what it is.
So here, you get e to
the minus lambda lambda
d d lambda of e to the lambda.
And that is lambda, OK?
So the expectation value of
the most sort of not the peak,
but the expected value of n in
this distribution, the level
that you're going to be
excited is basically lambda.
So if x0 is 1,000
times bigger than d0,
you've moved this thing 1,000
times the quantum uncertainty.
Then, you're occupying
most strongly the levels
at 1 million.
You get x0 over d0 controls
which n is the most likely.
Indeed, look, this
n-- suppose you
would compute x0
tilde n hat x0 tilde.
This is what you would think
is an occupation number.
This sounds a little hand wavy.
But this is the number
operator, the expected value
of the number operator,
in the coherent state.
But this is-- you have that
the coherent state is this.
So let's substitute
that in there.
So you get two sums
over n and over m.
And you would have
cm star m N n cn.
I've substituted
x0 and x0 dagger.
The c's in fact are real.
And then, the number
operator on here is little n.
And then, you get
the Kronecker delta.
So this is sum over n
and m cmcn-- it's real.
And then, you get n delta m, n.
So this is in fact the
sum over ncn squared.
So what we wrote
here, this is really
the expectation value
of the number operator.
And one can do more
calculations here.
A calculation that is
particularly interesting
to discover what
these states look like
is the uncertainty
in the energy.
So that's another sort
of relevant measure.
How big is the
uncertainty in the energy?
What are, basically,
the delta E associated
to the coherent state?
How does it look like?
Is it very sharp?
So it's a good question.
And it's in the notes.
I leave it for you to
try to calculate it.
Delta E in the coherent
state x0, how much is it?
And it turns out to be
the following-- h omega
x0 over square root of 2d.
So actually, maybe this
is a little surprising.
But delta E over h omega
is equal to x0 over d.
So actually, the
energy uncertainty
for a classical look in
coherent state-- I'm sorry,
I'm missing a square
root of 2 there.
So what is a classical
looking coherent state?
It's a state in which x0 is
much bigger than the quantum d.
So x0 is much bigger than d.
So in that case, this is a large
number for a classical state--
"classical" state.
But in that case, the
uncertainty in delta E
is really big compared
to the spacing
of the harmonic oscillator.
So you have-- here
is the ground state.
Here is h omega.
Here is the coherent
state, maybe.
And you have a lot of energy
levels that are excited.
So if x0 over this
is 1,000, well,
at least 1,000 energy
levels are excited.
But you shouldn't
fear that too much.
Because at the same time,
the expectation value of E
over delta E-- the
expectation of E
is something we calculated at
the beginning of the lecture.
You have the
oscillator displaced.
So this is roughly 1/2 m
omega squared x0 squared.
Throw away the
ground state energy.
That's supposed
to be very little.
Delta E is h bar omega
x0 over square root of 2.
And this is, again,
the same ratio.
So yes, this state
is very funny.
It contains an uncertainty that
measured in harmonic oscillator
levels contains many levels.
But still, the uncertainty
is much smaller
by the same amount than
the average energy.
So this state is a state of
some almost definite energy,
the uncertainty
being much smaller.
But even though
it's much smaller,
it still contains a lot of
levels of the oscillator.
So that I think gives you a
reasonable picture of this.
So you're ready for
a generalization.
This is a time to generalize
the coherent states
and produce the set
of coherent states
that are most useful
eventually, and most flexible.
And we do them as follows.
We basically are
inspired by this formula
to write the following operator.
And here, we change notation.
This x0 was here.
But now we'll introduce
what is called
the alpha coherent state.
Most general coherent
state is going
to be obtained by acted with a
unitary operator on the vacuum.
So far so good-- D
of alpha unitary.
But now generalize
what you have there.
Here, you put a minus
a dagger minus a,
because that was anti-Hermitian,
and you put the real constant.
Now this alpha will belong
to the complex numbers.
Quantum mechanics is all
about complex numbers.
You've got complex vector
spaces, complex numbers.
It's all over the place.
So how do we do this?
We do this exponential
of alpha a dagger.
And I want it to
be anti-Hermitian.
So I should put minus
alpha star a on the vacuum.
This thing for alpha
equals-- this real number
reduces to that.
But now, with
alpha complex, it's
a little more
complicated operator.
And it's more general.
But it's still unitary.
And it preserves a norm.
And its most of what you
want from these states.
So the first thing
you do to figure out
what this operator does
is to calculate something
that maybe you would not
expect it to be simple.
But it's worth doing.
What is a acting
on the alpha state?
Well, I would have
to do a acting
on this exponential of
alpha a dagger minus alpha
star a on the vacuum.
Now, a kills the vacuum.
So maybe you're accustomed
already to the next step.
I can replace that
product by a commutator.
Because the other ordering is 0.
So this is equal
to the commutator.
Because the other term when a is
on the other side is 0 anyway.
And now I have to
compute the commutator
of a with an exponential.
Again, it's a little scary.
But A with an
exponential e to the B--
it's in the formula sheet,
this Campbell-Baker-Hausdorff
again-- is A, B e to the
B if A, B commutes with B.
Well, this is A.
This is B. A with B
is-- A with B, the
exponent-- just alpha times 1
because of this.
So it's a number.
So this is safe.
So you get alpha times
the same exponential.
But the same exponential
means the state
alpha-- a little
quick, isn't it?
OK, A with B, this
factor, was alpha.
And e to the B anyway on the
vacuum is the state alpha.
So there you go.
You have achieved
the impossible.
You've diagonalized a
non-Hermitian operator.
This is not Hermitian, and
you found its eigenvalues.
How could that happen?
Well, it can happen.
But then, all of the
theorems that you
like about Hermitian
operators don't hold.
So it's a fluke.
This can be done.
But then, states that correspond
to different eigenvalues
will not be orthogonal,
and they will not
form a complete set
of states, and nothing
will be quite as you
may think it would be.
But still, it's quite remarkable
that this can be done.
So this characterizes the
coherent state in a nice way.
They're eigenstates of
the destruction operator.
And they're the most
general exponentials
of creation and annihilation
operators acting on the vacuum.
Now, we knew that when alpha
is real, it has to do with x0.
So we've put a complex alpha.
What will it do?
A complex alpha,
what it does is gives
the original coherent
state some momentum.
Remember, the original
state that we had was an x0.
And how did it move?
x0 cosine of omega t.
So at time equals 0,
it had 0 momentum.
This creates a
coherent state at x0,
and it gives it a
momentum controlled
by the imaginary
part of this thing.
In fact, we can do
this as follows.
You can ask, what
is the expectation
value of x in this state?
Well, x is written here.
It's d over square root of 2
alpha a plus a dagger alpha.
And look, these are
easy to compute.
a gives an alpha,
gives you alpha.
a dagger and alpha, you
don't know what it is.
But a dagger on [? brau ?]
alpha is alpha star.
So this one you
know on the right.
This one you know on the left.
It gives you the over
square root of 2 alpha plus
alpha star.
So it's square root
of 2d real of alpha.
So the real part of alpha is
the expectation value of x.
So I'll go here.
I'm almost done-- waiting
for the punch line.
Similarly, you can calculate
the expectation value
of the momentum.
It will be alpha p alpha.
And p is a minus a dagger.
So you're going to get
alpha star minus alpha, so
the imaginary part.
So p is actually
square root of 2 h
bar over d imaginary
part of alpha.
So the physics is clear.
Maybe the formulas
are a little messy.
But when you have an alpha,
the real part of alpha
is telling you where you're
positioning the coherent state.
The imaginary part
of alpha is telling
what kick are you giving to it.
And you now have produced the
most general coherent state.
So how do we describe
that geometrically?
We imagine it, the alpha plane.
And here it is.
The alpha plane, here is the
vector, the complex number
alpha that you've chosen
maybe for your state,
some particular
complex value alpha.
On the x-axis, the
real part of alpha
is the expectation value of
x over square root of 2d.
The real part of alpha
is the expectation value
of x over square root of 2d.
And the imaginary part of
alpha is the expectation value
of p over square
root of 2 h bar d.
And there it is, your
state at time equals 0.
What is it going to
do a little later?
Well, that will
be the last thing
I want to calculate for you.
It's a nice answer.
And you should see it.
It's going to take
me two minutes.
And what is it?
Well, alpha at time t, you
have to evolve the state-- e
to the minus iHt over h
bar on the state, which
is e to the alpha a dagger minus
alpha star a e to the output
and into the iHt over h bar,
and an e to the minus iHt over h
bar on the vacuum.
So I put the one here.
I evolve with this.
But I take the state
and put this and that.
This is simple.
It's e to the minus
iH omega over 2.
That's the energy
of the ground state.
But what is this part?
It's pretty much the
Heisenberg operator.
But the sign came out wrong.
Well, it didn't come out wrong.
It's what it is.
It just means that
what I have to put here
is the Heisenberg
operator at minus t.
Because I have t for minus t.
So this is e to the
alpha a Heisenberg at
minus t dagger minus alpha star.
I'm sorry, I have too
many parentheses here.
That's it, much
better-- minus alpha
star a Heisenberg of minus
t acting on this thing.
And what is this?
Well, we have the formula for
the Heisenberg states here.
So you've got e to the
alpha H a dagger of minus t
would be e to the minus
I omega t a dagger.
And here, you have
minus alpha star e
to the i omega t a
on e to the minus
i omega h bar over
2 times the vacuum.
And look what has happened.
Alpha has become alpha times
e to the minus i omega t.
Because the star is here.
It's minus the star one.
So the only thing
that has changed
is that this state,
alpha at time t,
is e to the minus
ih bar omega over 2.
I'm sorry, I'm missing a t here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I dropped--
yeah, minus i omega t over 2,
minus i omega t over 2,
times the coherent state, the
time independent coherent state
of value e to the
minus i omega t alpha.
That's a new complex number.
That's what has happened.
The number alpha has become
e to the minus i omega t.
Now, this is a face for the
whole state multiplicative.
It's irrelevant.
So what has this alpha done?
It has been rotated by e
to the minus i omega t.
So this at the time t
is the state alpha t.
Here is the state alpha.
And it has rotated by omega t.
So the coherent state
can be visualized
as a complex number
in this complex plane.
This real part is the
expectation value of x at time
equals 0 whose imaginary
part is the expectation
value of the momentum
at time equals 0.
And how does it evolve?
This state just rotates
with frequency omega
all along and forever.
All right, that's it for today.
See you on Wednesday.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Thank you, thank you.